de vuelta a la mesa de negociaciones
irán y eeuu inician una nueva ronda de
conversaciones sobre la cuestión nuclear
iraní- reavivando así las esperanzas de
una solución diplomática tras el fracaso
de las discusiones de marzo
espero que veamos resultados positivos
de estas conversaciones si washington
viene con respuestas a las demandas
iraníes podemos terminar el trabajo
rápidamente la pelota está ahora en su
campo el acuerdo de 2015 firmado entre
irán y eeuu francia alemania rusia reino
unido y china tras años de negociaciones
impuso restricciones al programa nuclear
iraní a cambio del levantamiento de las
sanciones económicas contra la república
islámica en 2018 bajo el mandato del
presidente de donald trump
eeuu abandonó el pacto y le impuso
sanciones a teherán que respondió
aumentando su tasa de enriquecimiento de
uranio las conversaciones se reactivaron
en abril de 2021 en marzo de 2022 los
negociadores parecían estar a punto de
alcanzar un nuevo pacto pero este no se
materializó el estatus del cuerpo de la
guardia revolucionaria islámica
encargado de proteger el sistema de la
república islámica es un obstáculo
importante washington considera a esta
organización como terrorista y se niega
a cambiar de posición hoy con la
mediación de la unión europea irán y
eeuu han decidido reanudar las
negociaciones si se alcanza el acuerdo
marcará al regreso del petróleo iraní a
los mercados internacionales un producto
cada vez más buscado desde la inversión
rusa y ucrania